new technologies are transforming the
way doctors diagnose patients especially
children one tech company called right
eye has a 90 second test that can help
determine whether toddler has certain
types of autism another company created
the face to gene app now this one uses
facial recognition to identify rare
genetic disorders in seconds Anna Warner
shows us the science behind these tests
and the people that they help
Keagan potato is a bright four-year-old
who also presented a medical mystery
he was much slower to grow all of his
things he did were delayed he speech was
slightly delayed crawling was delayed
doctors didn't know what was wrong until
Keegan's parents brought him here to
Delaware's Alfred DuPont Children's
Hospital where dr. Karen grip uploaded
his picture into an app called face to
gene to study his image I mean most
people looking at him wouldn't see any
thing at all other than he's a cute kid
yeah he is I didn't know that there was
anything in particular different about
him either and so that's why I was
really impressed that this app was able
to see something looking only at his
face the system developed by Company F
DNA uses the same facial recognition
technology as Facebook to look for
similarities or matches among images of
children with 8000 rare genetic
disorders so this is the condition that
showed the highest level of similarity
shown by this bar here completely filled
and this is the one this is this is the
one that Indians yeah he was diagnosed
with this in the end
in just seconds the app suggested Keegan
might have a metabolic disorder known as
Smith Laemmle Opitz syndrome it was a
quick answer and we knew right there the
app is just one of many new technologies
helping doctors reach a diagnosis more
quickly and efficiently another one
called right.i targets autism jack look
at the screen
doctors at the George Washington autism
center showed us how the test uses
infrared sensors to track what a child
like Jack here prefers to look at his
choices on one side people on the other
simple geometric shapes research shows
most children are drawn to the images of
people here on the right but toddlers
with certain types of autism instead
focus on the shapes on the left teste
inventor karen pierce we're categorizing
it as an autism risk if you look at the
geometric shapes more than 69% at the
time the chances that you have ASD are
exceptionally high the test can now be
used in a regular doctor's office right
eye chief science officer Melissa hunt
will they what used to be in the lab
that would take a long time to process
is now going to be available in many
locations providing instant results the
face to gene app is available in the
Apple Store but company CEO deco Gelman
says only medical professionals are
allowed access to the database we don't
want you know the mom and pops to go on
and download this app and use it to try
and diagnose their kids
that's the tantalizing question isn't it
I mean I can see a lot of people at home
saying wow if I had that app on my phone
maybe I could just figure out what's
going on with my child myself being
responsible as we are we don't allow
that we don't want people to go and get
anxiety over things that they don't
really understand it for CBS this
morning and a Warner New York